en toda la historia de Honduras.
Ahora hay 69, gracias a la ELAM.
Los problemas grandes requieren soluciones grandes,
impulsados por grandes ideas, imaginación y audacia,
pero también por soluciones que funcionen.
Los profesores de la ELAM no tenían bases en evidencia
para guiarlos, por eso aprendieron de la manera difícil,
con prueba y error en la práctica.
Incluso los estudiantes más brillantes
de estas comunidades pobres
no estaban preparados académicamente
para seis años de formación médica,
por lo que se creó un curso de nivelación en ciencias.
Luego estaba el idioma:
había mapuches, quechuas, guaraníes, garífunas,
indígenas que aprendieron español como segunda lengua,
o haitianos que hablaban créole.
Así que el español se convirtió en parte
del plan de estudios de pre-pre-medicina.
De todas formas, en Cuba,
la música, la comida, los aromas,
casi todo era diferente,
así que los profesores se convirtieron en familia, la ELAM un hogar.
Las religiones iban desde creencias indígenas
a yoruba, musulmán y evangélico cristiano.
Adoptar la diversidad se convirtió en una forma de vida.
¿Por qué tantos países
han solicitado estas becas?
En primer lugar, simplemente porque no tienen suficientes médicos,
y donde los tienen, su distribución
perjudica a los pobres,
porque nuestra crisis mundial en salud
está alimentada por una crisis de recursos humanos.
Nos faltan de 4 a 7 millones de trabajadores de la salud
solo para satisfacer las necesidades básicas,
y el problema está en todas partes.
Los médicos se concentran en las ciudades,
donde solo vive la mitad de los habitantes del planeta,
y dentro de las ciudades,
no están en los barrios pobres o en el sur de Los Ángeles.
Aquí en Estados Unidos,
donde tenemos la reforma en salud,
no tenemos los profesionales que necesitamos.
Para el 2020, tendremos una falta
de 45 000 médicos de atención primaria.
Y también somos parte del problema.
Estados Unidos es el principal importador
de médicos de países en desarrollo.
Segundo, los estudiantes acuden masivamente a Cuba
atraídos por los resultados de salud en la isla,
basados en un fuerte sistema de atención primaria.
Una comisión de The Lancet
ubicó a Cuba entre los mejores
países de ingresos medios en materia de la salud.
Save the Children identificó a Cuba
como el mejor país de América Latina para ser madre.
Cuba tiene una expectativa de vida similar a EE.UU.
y una mortalidad infantil más baja,
con menos desigualdades,
mientras gasta por persona
la vigésima parte de lo gastado en salud
aquí en EE.UU.
Académicamente, la ELAM es difícil,
pero el 80 % de sus estudiantes se gradúan.
Las materias son familiares,
ciencias básicas y clínicas,
pero hay diferencias importantes.
En primer lugar, la formación ha salido de la torre de marfil
hacia las aulas de las clínicas y los barrios,
lugares similares a donde trabajarán la mayoría de estos graduados.
Claro, también tienen conferencias y rotaciones hospitalarias,
pero el aprendizaje basado en la comunidad empieza desde el primer día.
En segundo lugar, los estudiantes tratan al paciente como un todo,
mente y cuerpo,
en el contexto de sus familias, sus comunidades
y su cultura.
Tercero, aprenden salud pública:
evalúan el agua que beben sus pacientes, sus viviendas,
las condiciones sociales y económicas en que viven.
Cuarto, se les enseña
que una buena entrevista con el paciente
y un examen clínico a fondo
proporcionan la mayoría de las pistas para el diagnóstico,
ahorrando costosa tecnología para la confirmación.
Y, por último, se les enseña una y otra vez
la importancia de la prevención,
especialmente de enfermedades crónicas
que amenazan con paralizar los sistemas de salud en todo el mundo.
Este aprendizaje en los servicios
también viene con un enfoque de equipo,
tanto la forma de trabajar en equipo
como la forma de dirigirlos,
con una dosis de humildad.
Al graduarse, estos médicos comparten
sus conocimientos con enfermeras, parteras,
trabajadores comunitarios de salud,
para ayudarles a ser mejores en lo que hacen,
no para sustituirlos,
para trabajar con los chamanes y los curanderos tradicionales.
Los graduados de la ELAM...
¿Están demostrando que este experimento audaz funciona?
Decenas de proyectos nos dan una idea
de lo que son capaces de hacer.
Tomen los graduados garífunas.
No solo regresaron a casa a trabajar,
sino que organizaron a sus comunidades para construir
el primer hospital indígena de Honduras.
Con la ayuda de un arquitecto,
los vecinos literalmente lo levantaron desde cero.
Los primeros pacientes entraron
en diciembre de 2007
y, desde entonces, el hospital ha recibido
casi un millón de consultas.
Y el gobierno está prestando atención,
señalando al hospital como un modelo
de atención rural en salud para Honduras.
Los graduados de la ELAM son inteligentes,
fuertes y también dedicados.
Haití, enero de 2010.
El dolor.
Personas enterradas bajo 30 millones de toneladas de escombros.
Abrumador.
Trescientos cuarenta médicos cubanos
ya trabajaban allí desde hacía mucho tiempo.
Más estaban en camino. Se necesitaban muchos más.
En la ELAM, los estudiantes trabajaron día y noche
para contactar a 2000 graduados.
Como resultado, cientos llegaron a Haití,
respondieron de 27 países, de Malí y el Sahara
a St. Lucia, Bolivia, Chile y EE.UU.
Se comunicaban fácilmente entre sí en español
y escuchaban a sus pacientes en créole
gracias a los estudiantes de medicina haitianos
que volaron desde la ELAM en Cuba.
Muchos se quedaron durante meses,
incluso durante la epidemia de cólera.
Cientos de graduados haitianos
tuvieron que recomenzar sus vidas,
superando su propio dolor,
para luego empezar a construir
un nuevo sistema de salud pública para Haití.
Hoy, con la ayuda de organizaciones y gobiernos
desde Noruega a Cuba y Brasil,
se han construido docenas de nuevos centros de salud,
dotados con personal y, en 35 casos,
dirigidos por graduados de la ELAM.
Sin embargo, esta historia de Haití
también ilustra algunos de los mayores problemas
que enfrentan muchos países.
Vean:
había 748 haitianos graduados de 2012, cuando se desató el cólera,
casi la mitad trabajaba en el sector público de salud,
pero la cuarta parte estaba desempleada,
y 110 habían abandonado Haití por completo.
Así que, en el mejor de los casos,
estos graduados ejercen
en los sistemas públicos de salud, fortaleciéndolos
y a menudo son los únicos médicos disponibles.
En el peor de los casos, simplemente no hay suficientes empleos
en el sector público,
donde se atiende a la mayoría de los pobres:
no hay suficiente voluntad política, no hay suficientes recursos,
no hay suficiente de nada,
solo demasiados pacientes sin atención.
Los graduados se enfrentan a la presión de sus familias también,
desesperado por llegar a fin de mes,
así que cuando no hay empleos en el sector público,
estos nuevos médicos viran a la práctica privada,
o van al extranjero para enviar dinero a casa.
Lo peor de todo, en algunos países,
las sociedades médicas influyen sobre las autoridades de acreditación
para no aceptar el título de la ELAM,
temerosas de que estos graduados les roben sus empleos o reduzcan
el número de sus pacientes y sus ingresos.
No es una cuestión de competencias.
Aquí en EE.UU., la Junta Médica de California
acreditó a la escuela tras una inspección rigurosa,
y los nuevos médicos demuestran estar a la altura
de la gran apuesta de Cuba,
aprobando sus exámenes y siendo aceptados
en residencias de gran prestigio,
desde Nueva York o Chicago a Nuevo México.
Doscientos regresan
a Estados Unidos llenos de energía,
y también insatisfechos.
Como dijera una graduada:
"En Cuba, nos enseñan a brindar una atención de calidad
con escasos recursos,
así que cuando veo todos los recursos que tenemos aquí,
y me dicen que no es posible,
sé que no es cierto.
No solo he visto que funciona, lo he hecho funcionar".
Los graduados de la ELAM,
algunos de aquí mismo en Washington DC y Baltimore,
han venido de los más pobres entre los pobres
para ofrecer salud, educación
y una voz a sus comunidades.
Han hecho el trabajo más pesado.
Ahora tenemos que hacer nuestra parte
para apoyar a los 23 000 y contando,
Todos nosotros,
fundaciones, directores de residencias, prensa,
empresarios, responsables políticos, personas,
necesitamos apoyar.
Tenemos que hacer mucho más a nivel mundial
para que esos jóvenes médicos tengan la oportunidad
de demostrar lo que valen.
Necesitan poder presentarse
a los exámenes para obtener las licencias de sus países.
Necesitan empleos en el sector público de salud
o en centros de salud sin fines de lucro
para poner a trabajar sus conocimientos y compromiso.
Merecen la oportunidad de ser
los médicos que sus pacientes necesitan.
Para avanzar,
quizá tengamos que retroceder,
volver a aquel pediatra que
tocaba a la puerta de mi casa
en el sur de Chicago cuando era niña,
que hacía visitas a domicilio,
que se debía a su comunidad.
Estas no son ideas nuevas
de lo que debe ser la medicina.
La novedad es la escala más grande
y las caras de los propios médicos:
Es más probable que un graduado de la ELAM sea mujer
en vez de hombre;
en el Amazonas, Perú o Guatemala,
un médico indígena;
en EE.UU., un médico de color
que habla perfecto español.
Ella ha recibido una formación sólida, se puede contar con ella,
y comparte el rostro y la cultura de sus pacientes.
Y, sin duda, ella merece nuestro apoyo
porque aunque viaje en metro, mula o canoa,
ella nos enseña a predicar con el ejemplo.
Gracias. (Aplausos)